I'll show you my implementation.
First off, I'm using date.now, and
I'm storing it to dateSubmitted in this object literal.
This is what becomes our note.
By the way, in case you're interested,
that number is the number of milliseconds since January 1st,1970.
Fun fact.
Well anyway, this is simple enough.
I'm just storing our current time into the dateSubmitted property.
Now, I've also added something down here in the view.
Down here in the view,
I've added a little piece of functionality to the render function.
When render is called, the date gets put into the HTML string.
Now a little note about this thing here.
I'm actually making a new date with that number, and
then I'm converting it to a string.
That ends up looking something like this.
Now it's not the most beautiful, readable date, but you can go in and
use some of the date methods to make it better if you'd like.
But the coolest thing is,
if you look back the amount of code hasn't really changed much at all.
We just have this one new line in the view, and
this one new line here where we create our notes.
Now one quick sidenote about this being in the octopus.
Strictly speaking, you can make the argument that this is kind of dataish.
Maybe it should be in the model.
And that's a totally legitimate argument.
In fact, a lot of organizational paradigms and
frameworks put this kind of a thing in the model itself.
Now for simplicity in this particular example, I'm not doing that.
I'm just creating an object literal right here, but
later on in the course, you'll see some of the interesting and
slightly more complicated ways that people form models.